how does one person listening to this  now you know they really want to be a an  entrepreneur they want to have a big  Media Company whatever it might be but  they don't know they don't have them  like but they're not objectively they  don't have Minerals Well how do they go  about discovering they don't have the  minerals by going in the pool and  drowning okay you know it's not for you  and I to judge because we've been wrong  too much yeah I've been wrong so much it  scares the [ __ ] out of me and I'm  when I'm dead I hope they can test for  it because I think I'm all time and I've  been wrong a ton that makes me believe  everyone's wrong so if you're listening  asking what you're in it for is  humongous